well how about that that you believe in
conspiracies I don't thank you do you
read the book you'll believe in any like
JFK you know that I'm right with you the
moon
none of that nothing so now it's
September eleventh now here's why no
none of that do you need any time that
thought enters your brain you need to
call a flower that thought you need to
scrunch it up and beat it up yeah beat
the [ __ ] out of it because why you're
that whenever I hear like there's a then
one of them is the the Rothschild family
controls all the government and I was
like oh yeah it's Nancy well semantics
when I go to the yet totally on tasted
mangoes like when I go to the DMV it
sucks and what can they can apparently
they're doing a terrible job
yeah and conspiracies are hard enough to
keep a secret between two people exactly
and they're hard enough to connect
between a thousand dollars Bali CIA
think about some one day I mean loose
lips sink ships was all through yeah was
like you do not tell anybody where we're
going don't go to a bar I that it's so
hard to keep a secret about anything
so the [ __ ] staged moon landing I
mean are you that's what I got that's
the mother's living a lie right Clinton
said if you were able to get a thousand
people to keep their mouths shut and
stand still yes III mean that would be
the greatest feat any human the
government and people don't behave that
way and and I'll tell you something
about the federal government they all
have their agendas and everybody's
backstabbing each other thank God for
you yeah but what about aliens go III
don't I haven't seen any proof of them
yeah believing them well I well I don't
I believe absolutely there are other
living things around our universe be way
too vast for that not to be happening
that the the coincidence and of other
planets being able to sustain life is
absolutely the percentages are very good
for that have you seen like some of the
tape like some of the pilots like in the
Air Force were the record this no I when
I see stuff like that I'm like well
that's a real thing and that makes me go
okay that's an actual there are things
you can't explain but it doesn't mean
yeah
I say like that was the same thing when
people like their seat there's
chemtrails and I was like what chemicals
what why would they do this my favorite
boxes that come out of your body well
well you got to sweat the toxins out and
they asked all these like people who run
these detox writers and they were like
and it's true that a doctor you can
detox for your liver and so when you
you've been an alcoholic there's ways to
detox there's ways to get heavy metal
out of your body but but for the most
part when they talk about detox when you
talk about being lead and they'll ask
they asked all these I kind of like
healers and these people who rip what
are the toxin named them if you could
name the talk oh right but that and they
God that's not a conspiracy theory it's
more of its Johnny it's just do stupid
it's way to go like this under present
natural yeah well everything is that's
exactly true toxin would be toxic to
your body yeah if you ingested diesel
fuel yeah you would truly have a touch
so that said so when I hear people go
the earth is flat which is a whole thing
wait and then they and then when I hear
people say like well I'll bet they'll
say stuff like and I'll be like well how
do you explain that was like well I
haven't seen that and I go like have you
been to Tokyo how do you know it exists
how do you know what charm exists how do
you know Mercedes is so I see it it's
just so it's on your skin and eating a
hole in your [ __ ] plate so it's more
people want they're missing something
from their lives and they want to have
on knowledge or or they also want to be
part of a community yes yeah behind them
it's like hate trolls on the internet
but it's also like well you only knew
your the conspiracy that the
government's against them right it's
just your the government is a huge messy
place every government is it's always a
mess and the simplest explanation is
usually the right one yeah which is
everyone's backstabbing and doing well
my but some of its shades some like my
JFK assassination now here we go
right you're not again just watch the
first 10 minutes of Full Metal Jacket
yeah and they'll be like I was a Marine
who it was a darn good shot and and why
you didn't have a good shot though
alright so everything that I've been
that window I've been it doesn't look
like a hard shot to me I haven't shot
deer personally
and I'll simply honey shotgun there's I
mean that's why the onion was so funny
when in our dumb century when it was
like Kennedy assassinated from 25
different angles and then it just listed
everybody who was like Teamsters have
you looked into it though it's it's
interesting we can see how if you are a
person who believes in conspiracies how
it's super easy to come to a few
conclusions it's the same no no nothing
no I got cuz I've K suspect and these
things come out eventually I mean
eventually even with even with Trump
because we have all these files on JFK
goes there's a portion I can't release
because it creates some sort of pandemic
come on there's an interesting I will
say no the once I thought pandemic but I
think is suspect the one thing that does
raise my prick Myers a little bit is
that when Jack Ruby shot Lee Harvey
Oswald and he was a mob guy and they let
him any they love shot to the police
yeah he shot him and we don't know why
and then he died of cancer in jail so
that there was something going on but I
don't doubt I wouldn't try to kill Lee
Harvey Oswald unless there was a reason
but well then what about that what about
this Joel what about this you so you the
car you ready
you really hammered my name the end of
that I'm just trying to really in about
Joel Joel well but how about the car
usually if there's a murder they take it
in for forensic and stuff like that you
know they cleaned it out and then
returned it okay maybe it's just that
you're not giving enough credit to
either human stupidity that's nice and
you might be right
so might you saying there's a lot of
mishaps are you if you try finding any
case criminal case where they didn't
screw up something on both sides yeah
and it's also people want to believe a
certain thing correct so they go for
that so find it dude you'll find if
you're looking for that sort of exact
what about epsteen epsteen oh that I do
not doubt that
those cops were in the jail I don't
think he was killed I think he
absolutely were already Wow I believe he
was absolutely ready to hang himself
me too I don't know why why would you in
your in his position and hearing stories
about negligence in that time yeah I
mean we just watch lockup well it's not
just that like one of these my father
who's eight days it's almost eight he
said it was worth government and
government had a lot of friends in
government flower Isis yeah yeah and one
of the things you always say is this
he'll go and anybody who I know who
works in government they're way more lap
to say well there's huge incompetence in
the government yes it's not there is not
a well-run place there are there are
major mishaps major flubs there's all
kinds of backstabbing that's what's
actually going on for the most part so
the idea that there's a cabal of men who
are organized enough to set things in
motion and everything goes according to
plan is Hollywood [ __ ] it's really hard
to do it's just people don't cooperate
things go wrong right it's just so III
for me it's not that I don't think that
people would want would be
conspiratorial minded if they could but
for me I I think it's just too hard to
pull off I don't think those things are
eat as easy to pull off as people
there's a very good book called
conspiracy a conspiracy me it's yes
called conspiracy V Wow conspiracy it's
about the takedown of Gawker the website
yeah
it's one of the whole consortium yes
Souter to to chill and it's a great book
and when you they go over it's so great
because almost half the book is like
here's how I can real conspiracy goes
down and they talk about when Peter teal
expanded it to two people and then to
three people all of a sudden things are
getting really it can all it it's
getting very tense on whether this
secret of what they're doing gets out
but that's a true conspiracy because
because Peter Thiel wanted to
essentially sue them until they out of
existence so that guy had this and a
Gawker had had outed psi they outed him
as a game that he's a billionaire and he
went I don't care what it takes I'm
gonna take him down and I'm gonna find a
way to do it without anybody knowing
what's the book of conspiracy so he
the G basketball it's just called
conspiracy but I don't want to ma'am I'm
letting up but it was very convenient
that the Hulk Hogan thing went down that
started happening like he took that it
wasn't ran with it he went like oh
that's an opportunity to exploit to
brighten to take them down again it's
great it's a great book and it's called
give and take now I'm gonna recommending
books
it was Apple Book of the Year in 2017 by
Adam grant really good book now do you
are you a reader I am wildly dyslexic so
I read nothing but I listened to
everything I listen to books on - yes
and right now I feel like when I listen
to books on tape I don't get as much
knowledge as fired actually I think it's
in practice I used to be the same way
and I practice now I can practice what
listening yeah because what happens is
your mind wanders as you're driving and
stuff so I sent a podcast
oh I gleaned so much more from listening
than reading I did now I do
yeah I'm just reading all the Jack
Reacher books now so cool which are
great yeah but conspiracy is definitely
I would I would recommend this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]